okay those are joining us on the live
stream we are talking about language
completeness and consistency for wolf
language heading for version 12.1 and
let's get started here okay ah what is
this can of worms partition padding with
no lists when applied to a function
right so I have sort of explanation of
how we got here and sorry Rob but I
think you just sort of screwed up a
little bit here it's Rob here yes I'm
here and no I don't think I screwed up
okay there's a great start
okay let's understand what the issue is
okay so he in order to do this he
changed the interpretation of the
padding argument which means that lists
are now considered Singleton's when
partitioning a non list so if you look
at the example there rather than
cyclically padding with a and B its
padding twice with you know the list a B
what was 301 604 it was a case where the
cyclical padding was not being done
correctly and I'm trying to remember
well it was it was it was a bug
basically it can I explain what logic
behind the code is so so the sick little
padding code is if the head matches the
expression okay it goes it it considers
that as a as a cyclical thing a list of
things to be padded so so so in this it
looks to take range of four here
okay range of four right there you go
just using that whereas in this case
here it's but
the list doesn't agree in head with the
F exactly Steve it is treating that as a
as a single as a single object which it
is then having to replicate twice right
exactly correct
okay and in that second one the
partition range of four if you had F of
a comma B you would not expect it to be
cyclical unless so that in that case of
that head is yet different again it
would be it would repeat itself twice
right exactly
okay so it's splicing when the heads
agree but it is not splicing when the
heads don't agree and that's the bug I
fix it wasn't doing that properly before
it's a change in behavior so this is
what it's doing so now that's doing now
so the argument from a tie is that this
should be different somehow the bad
output should be different there yes my
argument is that what that output has
been for the last you know 12 versions
or so or the previous 11 versions was
this thing comma a be that right yeah
it's it's basically list as a universal
head right which is you know if you look
at like pad left and pad right you know
it doesn't care what the head is just
what does pad left do I mean in the case
where if we say pad left of range of 4
comma 10 comma I don't know what the
right syntax yep right now put F of a B
and it will not Spencer quickly yes
which is correct and I maintain that
partition should follow this right now
if you have at at the range of 4 in
those 2 guys you'll see that it that
does it that does it with breaking them
apart whereas this will do it so this is
the big test drumroll
oh I see okay so that so whatever this
does has got to be consistent with what
this does all right so this in this case
list is being treated as a universal
head so to speak
some extent right okay well I mean that
the paired one isn't trying to do any
head matching right nobody's head
matching if I if I would know not know
it's it's not and I think that's a bug
and pad but but we can squash
I see look at that that's obviously
that's no that is consistent with the
document no that's right that's right
that's right but then this always is
because of the nature of that cyclicity
right so the documentation for laughs
and actually that parted the
documentation self for partition
although there there needs a couple of
weeks no matter what we decide today
state that if it's a list its
interpreted cyclically and if it's not a
list then its treated as a singleton and
I think we can still do that one day
we're having options as a way of
specifying I mean I wonder whether we
should have the possibility okay I've
got a radical idea for you guys that we
actually have a note a partition in
which we do this and then we have an
association with a bunch of named keys
that allow you to say things like
padding arrow whatever that won't solve
this problem I understand that I
understand that but this is that has to
do with you know partition understanding
so to speak do we think this is a good
direction to try and do something like
that or alternatively to have some
options as alternatives to the arguments
here because I mean it is kind of you
know frustrating that every time you use
this
you end up having to look up if you're
going to use a fourth argument situation
you know you have to go look it up right
yeah I'm trying to get it's it's a
different problem yes
solution to it Stephen coming up with
the names of the left hand sides yes
and then we okay but anyway look that's
all the problems in in in my how we got
here so before we get the straight boy
let's let's write right so in particular
that input below there right in previous
versions that would have been just F of
four there without those empty lists so
empty lists doing I mean the empty lists
well the default padding is empty list
and since he's now changed how we
interprets list it's it's sticking there
all right the default padding is open
list really yeah well in in the up to
spec right so right so he so that table
there of common setting for pad list is
actually wrong where it says default it
is default if you use a integer
partition spec or or but it is not
cyclic if you use an up to but but
you're saying that the obvious thing to
do here would be to have these null
lists just disappeared to have them be
nothing's well they can't be nothing's
lower case nothing well based basically
Steven what happens in the what happens
in the code is when you have a a head
the head with an empty empty argument it
turns itself in the sequence internally
I would expect the output to be yes do
you guys agree yes and that's what it
should be okay so so yeah I think I
think I've I've changed my opinion a bit
I think since each I found this this
inconsistency with pad and we have the
universal if thing I can probably I can
probably just revert back that changed
at the bug and and we're okay right so
I've even produced this this
which I you know unless somebody sees
some problem with it just review what
what you're saying is treat this as
always a container that will break so to
speak if it's a list the individual
elements are being applied cyclically
correct okay and if it's anything other
than a list even if no let me get
learner whistling if it agrees and head
no in the almonds there's no head
agreement in my proposal because that
wasn't the old behavior I see I think we
just make this universal that's and then
anything else is treated as a single
item correct yeah okay and and basically
with just a tiny bit of pre-processing
we don't even need to you know change
the guts of partition we just sort of
you know inch the head of the padding to
match for example grid will have a shoes
like this about cyclicity and and you
know when is it cyclic versus when is it
singleton elements right and Gregg
always interprets list as a list and
anything else is like list as in a
cyclic cyclic see right okay all right
so what is your what is your proposal
here right so basically keep basically
to restore the previous interpretation
of the padding and then I have here and
basically my then I have the suggested
algorithm so basically if the padding is
a list and arguin and the first argument
isn't a list then we just changed ahead
to you know the head of the first
argument so it's interpreted cyclic
internally so the internal code that
wants it to matching heads right
basically the problem is we have a
minute we had a mismatch between the
outer interpretation and the internal
code and Rob sort of made the external
interface match the inner internal code
and I'm here suggesting that simple
pre-processing step that well okay but I
don't think that's quite right because
in here like that would put in some F of
something's you don't want that you
don't want an inner f of X f of X
you know what weather would do in that
case it would instead of using lists
they would use empty lists it would use
F bracket bracket and then it would say
oh those should be sequences because of
the F I think I think I'm confusing you
by the sky but but I get what you I get
the output you're saying yes if the
parting is not a list well this is the
implantation I don't need to know this
this is right well it may be you know
I'll work on something like that it may
be more subtle for them for the
multi-dimensional what if what if it's
evaluated what if it evaluates I mean
then it matters what whether something
is actually has the head applied to it
or not so I'm saying I I I'm skeptical
about this detailed algorithm in the
sense that I I think it's very dangerous
to just apply an arbitrary head because
the thing may not evaluate with three
arguments but it may evaluate with one
argument although I think you have that
anyway it would just evaluate after
that's it's partition oh but you're
saying it was already that in the
intermediate stages if you if you
synthesize an f of X it could blow up no
it's it's in internally internally or
it's just structuring expressions in our
solution okay I just want to point a
minor issue in in the documentation then
so in that table about common settings
for pad lists it says pad by treating
list as cyclic default that's only true
if you're using you're not using up to
if you're using up to then it's its uses
an empty list for no padding by default
so we may okay so when they tell add a
note off to that table for that okay
okay can you just quickly show that bug
number again 301 301 604 got it thanks
okay onward next item right so this is a
suggestion we started to talk about it
last time but we didn't have we didn't
make very much progress and so I thought
I mean I'm personally opposed to this
suggestion but I guess I figured I would
give other people the opportunity to
weigh in but here I've identified sort
of you know a couple of obvious issues
and I'm not sure I see what the use case
for this syntax is right so the what
what the suggestion what the suggested
output in the suggestion is that last
there yes I see it which i think is fine
given that this operation is kind of
obscure I mean I don't really see the
only thing I can imagine being useful
though if somebody is not muted and it's
making some background I said that but
um the the only thing I can really see
as being useful is something which is
much more of a group by type operation
because I think this idea of in the
sequence of the Association chop off the
first n elements
I mean look I could imagine partition of
this comma three just gives the obvious
thing with with blocks of three from the
association you know with this this this
output right but as we just discussed
it's a partition keeps the head so by
all rights it should be an association
now the list no that's crazy right well
that would have to be a special case
because it can't keep the association
head has no keys to use right well do we
think that I think this function is not
super useful anybody else want to
comment on this house a do you have any
comments on this no I agree with you
that partition is nothing natural waist
associations all right
so why don't we somebody can write the
one line function for the function
repository Association partition and
this can be that function okay and we'll
see where it goes from that it becomes
the most super popular function then
we'll think again great so can I go now
then unless you unless we want to talk
about fast multipole moments but it's
probably not the right meeting for that
that's yeah that that'll be a fun
meeting but a different one all right
great um okay create file and truncate
file alright so so there isn't a
truncate file and I'm not sure we need
it
Constantine does point out an issue with
create file so sometimes you want to
sort of have a well-known place so you
can do create file with an existing you
know with a specified head and so sorry
with a specified name yeah that the
first argument there but the problem is
well if that file already exists
then it will just yell at you and so I
stand as opposed to just truncating it
to zero size right right so the
overwrite target thing which is
something from export and things like
that right it started I think it
actually started with copy file but yes
it's I think it's now in an export and
it's in you know move file or rename
file and I don't see any reason it
shouldn't be in create file seems like a
reasonable idea to me
right and so yeah you know the next
question is is there is it useful to
have a truncate file that truncates to a
certain length I couldn't find any use
for that what is the UNIX is there isn't
there a UNIX system come on for that
right except that works on streams
that's what I'm wondering is is is I'm
thinking why wouldn't we have this and
then realizing that I'm confusing files
and streams what does it do on a stream
it it it truncates the stream so the
idea is you wants to edit a file you
know let's say you want to remove the
last byte of a file then you can
truncate to a different length from the
current length basically length you know
file size minus 1 sorry what does that
have to do with streams that's for us a
file but I think it operates on us on a
stream right I think you have to do off
open and then you and then you have
truncate passing in the pointer the file
asterisk pointer that you got from the
fopen right so okay no there is there
there is a command line truncate in in
at least in oh that's true - yeah here's
one argument why you should have Duncan
file but without specifying the so if
you use a file as a log file
and sometimes when you restart
calculation you want to rate you want to
funky to zero and start over
that's this that's the system call not
the command line and I I think it right
so one of the slightly confusing things
about truncate right is that it might
actually increase the file if file isn't
as long as do fill with compliments
because those will be under file markers
necessarily cuz cuz you have to be able
to write zeros into a fun
yeah it's extended its extended and it
basically creates a hole so they're
basically zero by so they're effectively
zero bytes okay well could whoever's
thousand please
okay so the question here is do we want
something that is create file creates of
so you may want to turn key into an open
file yeah but where would you truncate
you truncate at the beginning or the end
I mean I can imagine if you have a log
file you might just want to keep a
running kind of journal thing of the
last 500 you know it's like a tail -
whatever it is right exactly I mean I
never used truncate because I will
either use head or tail depending on you
know and for log files right it's
typically tail that I want except you
feel you for how long output you and for
the if you run your calculation again
you're not intercept in the previous
mode so you want to discard what's in
the file and start to work that's why I
don't get this right so right so I tail
it and then I well I guess I guess you
potentially have overriding issues okay
but look look the question is I mean on
the live stream and Genesis is asking
about touch file but I think touch file
we already have what is it it's file
what the heck is it actually what's that
or is that set file I don't think it's
touch file I think it's the same thing
as set I think that's equivalent I think
set file date without a date is
equivalent to touch think so that touch
creates file if it's not there no it
doesn't yes it does yes it does so it's
a combination of grades file and since
all dates right so basically a create
file with an override target just to
true well no that wouldn't be a touch
it's not the greatest naming that the
word touch will create a file I didn't
even know that in all these years I
didn't know that um a we go on sorry
yeah no I was about I was about to say
something wrong
so I don't know that sentence
on this topic though because truncate at
least the stream version of it is useful
when you're working when you're doing
random access rates which is I think
something we don't have and so another
way of saying that correct me if I'm
wrong sets stream position only works on
input streams not output streams right
and so I think it could to work on
output streams as well look it was a
project from the early 1990s to have
readwrite streams we never did it do we
care mmm I mean generally in the yeah I
don't even know whether the modern UNIX
world has changed but back in the day it
used to be you'd open it for reading or
you open it for writing can you now open
it in some kind of read write mode yes
and that's to semantically I mean if you
read from the file if you write it and
then read it what is it what it what
happens to the stream pointer is there
one point or two pointers no it's one
pointer and so the point is you could
you can open it in read write and append
mode for example so that it's not so
that you didn't truncate to the file and
when it was opened and which means that
its previous contents are still there
and then you can set the stream position
anywhere you want and overwrite bytes
and then the stream position is the
point immediately after the last write
and then if you want to you can just
start reading from there yeah and and if
if you literally opened an append mode
so that you are writing to the end of
the file then trying to read will of
course depend to file I think this is a
somewhat major project to over whole
stream code I had the highest priority
and I think it's not right now
I I agree with that and given that we
haven't finished some basic things like
you know character encodings and input
streams you know I
to choose that over a right so with
respect to truncate file is it something
that's implementable in top-level as a
function
no but it's quite easy to do yeah I mean
the question is okay I I personally
think we should skip this I don't think
it's that important okay um so right now
I don't see the if we're flooded with
requests after this switch session then
we can reconsider fine I was actually
okay well okay look if I use log files
for debugging
well okay then let's talk about the
semantics of it okay because I don't
think the name is right I don't think I
think the use case of interest would be
I mean look here's an example of
something that would be useful being
able to open a file with the statement
don't let this file ever be more than
10,000 bytes
okay so in other words it's a limited
size file and as you add stuff to the
end it deletes stuff at the beginning
making sense so it's opened in append
mode but it is a fixed size file so it
doesn't you know when you append stuff
at the end it deletes stuff at the
beginning if it's too big it's like a
buffer
yes for example I mean is that is that
not what you would want for for you know
having a log file for debugging if it's
literally a file it seems like that
would mean linear time every time you're
writing something well have to modify in
every single byte in the file now what
you just called me is not what I want
because I don't know the the size of the
file I just I just need a simple
operation that when I start the
calculations over I need there I need a
clean work file so so we're gonna have
create file with override target yes
so that will zero out the fly
the question is do you care about having
a file that maintains a fixed size
you're claiming it's algorithmically
hard to do if you want to unless you say
well don't worry about the size until
after I've done the eye it doesn't make
sense to me I don't think this does I
don't think this is something critic
okay yeah and I think yeah and in fact
the way I think this is normally handled
as by you know date rotation right so
every does right day week whatever you
copy it over to a new name and now
arguably we should have some utilities
for date rotation I mean that would be a
nice thing at least we could get a
function repository function for doing
that create a file corresponding to the
state hardly the most complicated thing
but that might be a useful thing to have
make sense not sure well it doesn't
matter it's a you know we can write it
in five minutes or something it's just a
date string thing with a with a you know
whatever I think a lot for the function
repository it's not a built-in system
function right now I'm just saying that
that sort of so you know right not
people what people normally use for date
rotation right they they'll move right
they'll have you know log file and then
log file - one and log file - two and
right you you either discard after so
many logs right and then you just rename
them right so when you do the rotation
the current one becomes - one - one
becomes - two etc really yep have you
take a look in VAR you know var log so
you do that operation so you take every
function you you slide its name down yep
weird yeah so if you if you if you okay
that's that fine I don't need to do it
but I mean that that's a that might be
okay fine so I'm their function
repository functions that might be
useful I think the thing about having a
date creating a directory you know
having something which has I mean I have
many many many directories with
by months and things like this mm-hmm
and that would be having some utilities
associated with that would be nice but I
probably should it I probably have those
somewhere myself anyways is Sushma on
the school yep yeah well then then um
that seems like it's a function
repository thing okay all right let's
move on to the next item file
permissions designer functions to check
file permissions which we do not have
right now we have we have we have
information which gives some you know
which I think give right it has the UNIX
permissions and so if I say information
file etc password for example yep no W
or R oh yeah
okay so right so you have that string
there and you have the numeric right so
you have the sort of symbolic and
numeric representations but if you want
to ask can I write to this file right
you'd have to take this string and
somehow process it yourself also in
Windows you don't have unix permissions
and there are no permissions country at
all oh well that's that's an unfortunate
defect that we should probably because
there's no way okay so this is set
permissions for a cloud object
generalizing that to a file seems like
it's the first obvious thing to do and
we've also got permissions let's see
that's an option that's the option for a
a cloud object they don't know how you
query permission just say options so I
mean if I say if I would say cloud pup
deploy let's say um you know one two
three
then that will give me that and if I say
options of that , permissions there's
what I get
okay now if you ask the question if you
have a question about those permissions
like is it writable I mean other words
is that what policy you know is this
file writable by me for example is this
file writable by so-and-so we do not
have a language for querying that type
of thing right and that would be
certainly if you're if you're doing
systems programming that would be the
most important well it may be setting
but certainly querying so you know if if
you can actually open you know create
that file open that file etc is perhaps
the most important thing well maybe I
mean so so this will be if the file is
writable right then open it for writing
it's for example or if it's not given
our message or something so location
mapping permissions to all systems to
windows will be difficult because it has
completely different system but having a
set of predicates like this connect in a
writer file that that may work because
we matter differently for different
systems right so things like I mean we
certainly have in inside notebooks we
certainly have notions like editable for
example right yeah yes but I don't quite
understand how these would be so I mean
so so I think that I mean they think the
sort of functions that you know that
Constantine would want would be
something like check permissions or
check permissions Q of you know object
come
reading or writing or executing and then
option you know by default it means you
know me and you can give like group
world or you know check permissions
object comma then the action and then
possibly by I mean it could also be
something more like owner - action right
but you see this is kind of complicated
because with the user metadata stuff of
a cloud object it could be that that
thing you might say at 5:00 p.m. from I
don't know you know Venezuela or
something I don't know what um you know
and we have that ability to you know
from the user metadata restriction stuff
we have the ability to decide that based
on time geolocation etc right so there's
a little bit more to this because you
really what you want to do is ask it are
you are you saying that you can change
permissions wasting time yes yes that's
the idea right so what it is in
particular is this owner thing right
what you do is you get to say this range
of times this set of geo locations has
these permissions okay am I making sense
and a different time might have you know
for example it might be writable from
9:00 to 5:00 but not in any other time
okay so you would have instead of the
owner there you would say something like
you know time I forget what it is time
range or something arrow and then 9:00
to 5:00 and then then that arrow read
right and then for example the default
case would be it's only readable for
example right so right so I guess I have
sort of two responses that one is well
maybe we need a separate check file
permissions which it is you know less
complicated or
I mean certainly them I think the most
important case is can I now have this
permission right you know what is you
know sir and it may be that right it
could be the sort of thing of if we're
going to do this for general not objects
not all objects support all possible
syntaxes but certainly you know can I
now do read write or execute is an
answerable question and and then an
important one for any sort of scripting
yes so maybe we need them on a bake
permissions object which would
encapsulate for various data like this
so we can you don't have to represent
that in this particular form but you can
query it well that's a big deal because
I mean the permission structure is
pretty complicated the full I don't even
know whether it's in I forgotten whether
it made it into twelve order that's
coming from probably nobody in this
meeting knows that anybody know that I
have not noticed any major updates to
permission so I look look start date and
date okay right oh yeah I remember this
Yeah right there we go location country
and so on boy I don't think we mentioned
this in the new and twelve stuff no I
mean this only came were like when we
were like six weeks I'm trading the
marketing materials okay so by the way
that's a bug and we should probably fix
it that the new and twelve should get
that should that should mention this
okay um rewriting history slightly I
mean as in we got to go back and okay so
Wow okay
all right so this is kind of elaborate
mm-hmm but what it is doing is it's
saying given a user metadata string can
that person have this permission and by
the way the permissions that they can
have you know there are various
permissions here like like these ones
for instance now notice that those
permissions map on to the individual
within notebook editable selectable and
so on
this is a kind of complicated area we're
not going to get this resolved today but
I do think that the idea of a check
permissions object operating on an
object asking about an action is a good
idea
mm-hmm and I mean I I think that the
simple case of this which is check
permissions object comma you know right
for example you know can I write this
now is it's pretty obvious than done
controversial yet yes still information
of file if you ask for permissions
what should return because argument for
generations what are you talking about
[Music]
okay what do what do we have in there
what we have here is unix permissions
code for example fine which is that
that's a string right yes
and unix right so there was an idea that
we should also have a permissions that
gives the file permissions in the same
form as this permissions option suitable
to me probably makes sense so which
would probably just be a list of rules
given that it's a function it should be
the right hand side of the permissions
option yeah for this file right I don't
know enough I mean the constant
do you understand the windows permission
window start about parish's it's more
complicated right that that much I knew
I think it's I mean I think they have
for like the old VMs like read write
create execute or delete I mean a delete
read write delete and and I think it's
also very heavily based on access
control lists rather than groups by the
way it's pointing out that um the that
information of file does not show
extended access control list permissions
for Mac OS that yes that is a part of
permissions what does that look like do
we have a symbolic representation of an
access control list or not and how does
it map into our own cloud object access
control right right so that is trying to
remember how do you get that on so I
don't remember how you get it on Mac so
right basically every file certainly
every platform and possibly every file
system has its own notion of access
control lists and so you need but I
think on Mac they look roughly like you
know this user gets these permissions in
addition to the base ones but you don't
get them from LS you need a separate
command which I don't remember at the
moment I thought it was a matter of
adding something to the LS LS tell me
you thank you
LS - le where do I see anything special
oh you don't
there's nothing special about it let me
see if I can figure out something that
is special try it on till the library
till the slash library right me daddy
also know ok yeah yeah logs can't be
deleted Wow
so yeah so this is way more advanced
than ext 63 ACLS
alright so basic point here we need to
understand this better but this war
required different set of people because
it's the people who worked on cloud
permissions possibly also cell
permissions right ok so and we'll need
the platform experts right because each
that's correct
ok well let's get a meeting together
about these and try and nail it but I
think the general direction we're going
in is a check permissions type thing
okay and those are common here from
Mohammed on the livestream might be nice
to have a way to elevate the permission
of dollar system shell in commands like
run process isn't that a different thing
I'm sorry I was momentarily distracted
ok so the issue is if you run if you run
run process with a system shell there's
a way I mean what you're effectively
doing is a pseudo there aren't you if
you want to change that the permissions
level isn't that what you do with pseudo
are like totally confused as well that
the point is that running system shell
is not gonna run things as sued you if
but yeah if you want to change ownership
of files then you need to sue do if
you want to change permissions of files
you own yourself you don't need to do if
you want to change permissions other
people's files then you need see right
but um this person's making on the live
stream is that it would be nice to be
able to do that but we don't we have a
mechanism
what is our sudou mechanism because we
have a secure remote secure shell right
we've got SSH which is right but that's
that has nothing to do with sudo okay
okay so walk me through ok so I mean in
the generic dilute use of ok so sooner
we have to bring up an authentication
dialog wouldn't well the lutely
yeah until and then it would do the same
thing in recording the password in the
system keychain so that you can do it
again right is that correct
possibly you do multiple su dues you
don't have to type the password every
time but that's the operating system
that's doing that and and it only does
that for a maximum of five minutes and
on some some systems it has to be in the
same shell okay okay so when principle
one could store the credentials in the
system keychain using system credentials
isn't that correct right so then the
possibility would be if you want to do a
sudo operation so if you if you're
saying run and you say you know do that
with authentication arrow whatever you
could imagine doing that or something
like that well isn't that the case that
when you do the run what is it that's
exact or something
well it's yes exactly
which means it's going to run has been
sh unix yeah and see I would expect
maybe there are ways that I don't know
where I'm not thinking of but I would
expect that what you actually need is to
be able to upfront launch a process as
root which means that you have to have
either launched Mathematica itself or
your Wolfram language engine as route or
we need to have a binary in the system
with the asset UID bit set and that
latter scares me
I see what you're saying okay well
there's an old sorts of useful comments
from Lazaro on our live stream basically
saying this is incredibly complicated
this is it
yeah I mean we're clearly not gonna make
progress in this discussion but um okay
it's commenting on the whole s IP and
Mac OS I don't know what that is system
integrity integrity protection and and
that's one of the reasons why what I
said scared me I'm saying it's not a key
chain that determines the sudou thing
the timeout is set by etc sudoers right
okay it should use P a.m. to
authenticate I don't know what that is
what is that that is the password
authentication manager it's it's a
library it's a system library that
manages things like right so this is a
big can of worms and we're not gonna
solve it here and right it's pointing
out that not using that one doesn't use
the system keychain where it Pam is a
global way of setting authenticating
passwords what does that mean because I
thought our plan for was to use the
system keychain to store a bunch of
external authentication passwords is
that not correct constant in it is also
so now what is this comment about how
yeah yeah right I think the point is
that what Constantine is talking about
is completely orthogonal to the question
of escalating privileges and so and and
so you can't use the same key chain that
okay I understand so they're three
different things we're talking about
here we talk about file permissions
we're talking about privileges for
running a command on the local system
and we're talking about things like you
know soaring API credentials or SSH
credentials those kinds of things
yeah and that it's that latter thing
that last thing that we intend to use
system credentials in the system
keychain for that correct yep okay all
right let's move on I think I think this
as far as we're gonna get today on this
but let's come back and talk about a
check permissions idea later okay next
item filling what the heck does this do
I mean that that attempts to be a
filling between so if I say plot sine X
cosine X well and I need a tan X here
but then I say filling arrow well
actually let's just say one arrow list
to Union X range thank you okay that's
rather magnificent what the hell those
asymptotes doing I never saw those
asymptotes before don't know if it's in
is this a 12o or master branch was the
twelve oh where are those coming from
let's just take a look and they're
coming from tangent yeah I know that
coming from you yeah oh wait a minute
that doesn't give them if you say
fallacious wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute are they something to do
with filling that's what I'm wondering
that is really weird oh my gosh that's
like that you think that's a part what
is it what what first of all why isn't
there filling yeah where is the filling
I mean if I say filling arrow access for
example that'll work
okay what does filling arrow true what
is filling arrow true supposed to do I
don't know if it has a documented
behavior or jumps interesting it's
probably trying to fill from zero from
the curve to the number true and failing
right is my guess no I don't think so
well let's take a look at what would
happen if we just said filling arrow
zero for example filling arrow let's say
filling arrow one
okay that's happy try filling a phone
goes to a okay so that's not the same
thing as true okay so then yeah I guess
I shouldn't doubt you Bret when we're
talking about this link okay v6 we may
have had something in mind for true and
it was just never completed or something
but I don't remember what it was well
but what is filling arrow true
generically do so if I just say plus a
mean
okay great okay because that's do it
with two curves it's a shortcut for like
one to two two to three or something
like that oh so it is and so what's
happening is probably doing it between
that's super confusing what is the
course was feeling and yeah okay so
what's that doing
yeah so it's filling one to two and then
two to three a things okay
fine but but it's getting tripped up by
tangents somehow it's getting tripped up
by the asymptotes I mean in other words
if and it seems like if I were to say
something like tan X let's say SEC X
this is going to really confuse it
because it's going to be and let's say
well coat an X it's rather pretty but
but okay I just just followed the
coloring right it's going from 1 to 2
and then from 2 to 3
but it's correctly doing that right so
there it's correctly getting those
rather a nice plot I think you're still
getting that really thin line at the
asymptotes you just can't tell because
it's blending in with the blue what do
you mean
so if I were to say for example
cotangent plus PI over 10 for example
what does that why is that not doing
something sorry I'm confused here
oh you think there's an asymptote line
yes there is there's an asymptote line
there and if I say filling style
Eero yellow oh for goodness sake I know
look look look look look look you see
that see that crossing over there well I
can see it so maybe just barely yeah
right there's a little glitch there as
it closes over trifling style goes to
nothing
ooh what for Oh okay try opacity of zero
it suppose that might also affect the
asymptotes yeah yeah yeah so all right
okay all right let's go back to the
original so there's some bug here which
has to be tracked down or miss feature
okay so let's talk about filling one
arrow to what what is that supposed to
do and why is that significant so that
fills curve one two curve two and it
probably helps if you look at the email
thread which I think Sushma okay okay
this business okay that was that was my
plot um okay what do gridlines have to
do with filling hey I don't understand
have that so what's happening here is
the filling is completely obscuring the
gridlines and Steven suggests that the
gridlines should be in front and I
suggest that whatever's causing the
filling to be opaque here was probably
not intended right well let's get a
picture here let's get this picture
actually I had I had another objection
okay recently the date list plot I could
not figure out how to get dots at every
point in date list plot really well
let's let me show you something one
second here markers goes to automatic
probably in mesh goes to true
I tried mesh goes to true it's not
working or maybe it's a bug maybe it's
something else up something here um to
put up something nice and exotic
I have got this is this crazy spacecraft
that crashed on the moon last week that
yes had some of our material on it and I
have data what's that Bereshit yes um
and this is it's yeah we can't we can do
the physics debugging here as well I
could not figure this out this is the
vertical speed as a function of time and
okay so what I wanted to do here was to
take the what I want to do is I've got
data on the vertical speed as a function
of time okay there we go
okay so my goal here is to do a dateless
plot which um oops dateless plot of this
right so I say dateless plot that and
now what do you say I mean if I do this
by default it will join everything now I
want to put the if I say measure or true
watch the badness that happens that is
not this mesh Oh Mitchell how would I
ever know that and you'd need percent
wrists well now you need to know yeah
right okay I can put this data in there
um okay okay if anybody can figure out
why this thing is falling at 0.5 eight
meters per second per second rather than
lunar gravity which is one point six six
meters per second squared
I don't know I'm very confused and and
it also appears to be violating Newton's
first law um because it I'm very
confused by this um but that's a
difference um a different issue okay so
here the issue is let's say I have it
let's let's imagine let's just take this
as an example I want to have a band of
by the way does it document this in
dateless plot I mean I certainly didn't
and just take a look here
the mesh are all what it actually does
how many mesh points to draw in each
line and now if I go there it's kind of
super obscure if I might say so I mean
it's in the examples right if you go to
options right and I'm sure there will be
okay for me a very bad day for me to be
sure apparently okay so that needs to
Brett that's young fix um okay so is
there something we needed yes yes okay
so hold on hold on the next issue is
let's imagine here in this thing that I
want to put in grid lines arrow true
okay okay that's hunky-dory now let's
see what happens if I say grid lines to
true and filling goes to okay now that
puts grid lines in on top of the filling
there behind the filling there behind
the filling but there's an opacity right
the default opacity is like one half of
the curve okay I think what you're
running into you probably had something
like filling style goes to light blue
yes okay fine
it was opaque okay but so what's your
point here so in in the in the case here
let's imagine that I put the filling
here in okay hold on let's just do a
simpler case here so let's say plot sine
X actually what I want to do is this I
want to say plot I'm trying to get two
curves where I can fill between those
curves but I don't actually want the
curves themselves and then I want to put
another curve on top
okay um okay so I want to fill between
let's see if I can figure out how to do
this I want to I want to say filling
from curve one to curve two right that's
gonna give me that anything oh I picked
a particularly stupid example here let's
go let's say 3 sine 3 cosine okay so
it'll intersect like that okay now I
don't you want to show the those first
two curves so I want to say plot style
and a row let's say none none red okay
yeah okay so now that curve correctly
goes on top of the filling or are you
saying the filling is is actually on top
of the curve but the curve no I don't
believe no no I mean so the right the
curve is on top because it's the third
curve and well you know if you're
sinking through the front it might look
different
okay so let's try that okay so now I
want filling two to three and then this
plot style red none none right no okay
but now let me try adding to this um
grid lines what I think you want
automatic or didn't it working take this
plot I did so something's wrong
okay well that was working fine right
now if you make plots or feeling style
goes to you know orange I see humph
well it's not obvious that this is wrong
right in here what will happen I mean
what would happen is I mean the
gridlines can either be all the way at
the back or all the way at the fore at
the front yeah and I don't think you
obviously wrong
I mean if this is documented somewhere I
don't think it's obviously wrong okay so
is there now an issue here is is there
some remaining issue or was that does
this resolve that issue I think that
resolves it the only question is you
know if you say filling style goes to
lighter of orange should it still have
the default opacity or should it just be
the lighter of orange what is the
default opacity like point four okay so
if I would say opacity here point four
and then lighter of orange then because
of the bizarre rules of opacity which
don't care about order is that not
correct for the most part now what's
this for the most part mean is there any
case where they do care about oh yeah if
you have multiple things with opacity
strictly between 0 and 1 right the order
in which you layered them could have an
effect especially in 3d but I see all
right okay this is a non-issue so we
have one mystery here with the spelling
true with asymptotes which we should
nail down um although it's not obvious
it's bad behavior but it's just a bit
odd I'm not
we expected right okay so Stephen Brett
and I are late for another meeting so
unless you think either of these is
urgent I would suggest we postpone them
for another time all right well let's
just pre meeting for this one for a
second and then then we'll go but but um
okay this is about call out highlighted
all the other things working in graphics
I am gonna make a big push to have that
happen
even though I know Brett thinks it's a
bad idea so far in other words you know
the notion that graphics is purely inert
and can't have things that are labeled
and call out it and so on I think it's
so confusing and I just don't think I
think it's super useful to have
something which has is both you know
graphics laid out and has a call out
sister so okay so so the meeting that is
that Emma emailed about last night is
labeled and highlighted and all right
fine so that's this item here no I'm
clarifying that that's that's hard to
tackle all of that in one meeting well
it's not all that I mean it's a big
policy issue right um okay so you by the
way claiming that this just works and my
example here are you claiming that this
is a non-issue because this just works I
mean that one will just work I mean
it'll take a little bit of time but so
you're saying the the question is where
the geo smooth histogram should respect
country borders and so on right
I mean and I'm open to having something
like you know a special value like
region function goes to string land or
something yes I mean it seems like that
could be useful I mean I I think that
this is a bit goofy you know this this
is showing Wow
it's locked up doing something here but
this is showing I'm that's showing the
density of distinct Wow oh that's super
cool wowie
I haven't looked to see what's going on
with Italy at the moment I'm not sure if
it may be a plot point sampling issue or
something weird I mean what this is is
you take I think the Centers of all
historical countries and you superimpose
them on top of each other and you ask
where they are the most common and the
answer is that part of southern Europe
seems to be the one which is at least
the center of the most weird stuff going
on isn't for what it's worth
okay we have one last comment here from
vero vero um about the pseudo question
I'll just paste what they say in here if
I can I may not be able to but let's try
it this is about a pseudo question so
you know numbers what you've already put
in your password and whether to prompt
you again it's in far runs who do shrink
there's a list of each user in each TTY
and the time they lost authenticated
right that's roughly that is the correct
you know I thought you know that sounds
like my understanding of how pseudo
operates so it knows where each TTY and
you know if you have a time out that
it's actually fairly interesting
workflow which which I could imagine us
using for some of the cloud
authentication stuff I was not aware of
that I didn't know about that timeline
I've used pseudo for what is it now
forty years close to but um I never
really noticed what I just noticed
sometimes it asked me for my password
and sometimes it didn't um okay that's
interesting I mean I wonder whether we
could use that in that kind of idea in
any of the cloud authentication stuff
that we have and I suppose that there's
similar mechanisms in OAuth right off as
timeouts also
um those who say as well as I can tell
that's some something like how the
authentication for our webmail works
fair enough you know that it has a good
12 hour timeout or something and your
network or sometimes want to point out
look at look at the edge of France and
Spain here
something went presumably went wrong
right because because this smooth
histogram it whatever is the case I mean
even if there was no great empire that
that launched and the you know in some
you know some piece of Normandy that
there it's still the case that the this
coloration should extend to the edge of
France right I mean it may be that
that's a resolution issue with the
polygon for Europe or that I mean a
discretization thing on where the you
know the points that define that
gradient are I see what you're saying
right so because you haven't thought
about region function in connection with
the gradients for the smoothing for the
histogram well I mean it's just a normal
region function thing right so so it
doesn't necessarily do but the region
function should be adaptive subdivision
I get it but it should be a cookie
cutter it shouldn't allow anything
outside of the region well anyway right
like that gap you know connecting IDEO
Italy to the Adriatic bridge we might
call it right you know it's possible
that you know the underlying points and
the density plots are both on land I
serve I mean all
you know that you have points that are
on land and nothing that's in the
Adriatic there right okay I see the
easternmost tip of Spain is also missing
so maybe this was just written by a
Catalan separatist okay and look what
happened to Ukraine there look what
happened to what is that that's a that's
um Crimea isn't it yes anyway never mind
let's not let's not even go there all
right okay good
all right let's wrap this up okay okay
live stream folk Sushma I think I'll
send you I saved this back to the
original location unless this is I think
I need to send this to you okay thanks
guys
bye